for many Rasheeda Talib story of her
Palestinian grandmother's humiliation
told a familiar tale as a young girl
visiting Palestine to see my
grandparents and extended family I
watched as my mother had to go to
dehumanizing checkpoints I remember
shaking with fear when checkpoints
appeared in the small village of Bethel
and força tanks and guns everywhere
Talib and Ilhan Omar the two u.s.
members of Congress were denied entry
into Israel after President Trump urged
Israel to ban them in a tweet he said it
would show great weakness of Israel
allowed representative Omar and
representative clay to visit they hate
Israel in all Jewish people and there is
nothing that can be said or done to
change their minds on Monday they fired
back at the president so we are gonna
hold our head up high and we are going
to fight this administration and the
oppressive Netanyahu administration
until we take our last breath they
invited others to share their stories of
what they called the human cost of the
Israeli occupation Amber Harris a Jewish
US resident said Israel's sent her home
and held her Palestinian husband until
he could resolve his own visa problems I
was held interrogated for ten hours by
the Shin Bet the Israeli Security Agency
my marriage documents were almost thrown
away and I was humiliated
israeli-palestinian issues weren't
always so partisan in US political
circles but with the fiery rhetoric
coming out of the White House and the
makeup of Congress changing both
Republicans and Democrats alike have
grown more contentious the US
administration is giving no ground in a
statement White House spokesman Hogan
Gidley said Israel has a right to
prevent people who want to destroy it
from entering the country and Democrats
pointless congressional inquiries here
in America cannot change the laws Israel
has passed to protect itself that echoes
the Israeli prime minister by law we are
not willing to admit into Israel those
who call for the boycott of the State of
Israel and act to delegitimize the state
of the Jews
with Netanyahu and Trump both facing
upcoming elections
their alliance shows no signs of
breaking anytime soon John Hendren al
Jazeera Washington